welcome to this video playing grand
master my master and he's got the
Turkish flag Kevon Hudson hosny the
whole really this is a GM I other so
many gf's iana alright so let's see me
and hims oh no almost sure I Williams oh
but he's going to the Benoni
I have pretty good results at least
positions with this nightie to 2g 3m
line protecting eform and yep h5 i think
i can actually do that
yeah plug to Castle a because this also
allows night h1 in case of them attack
okay Queenie 7mm this already time for
some punishment like f45 come on let's
try that it's prob able to to crude but
I always feel provoked by the Benoni to
be honest it seems like an awfully
ambitious opening came if I've and f5
this is probably too quick oh come on if
it's not working what the heck is just
the Blitz game yep this was clear and
now he seeks was my idea
yeah if you would have taken twice I
think what you should have done Knight
f6 really looks very strange now I can
play a five and this looks like like
it's in terrible shape cannot cannot
believe that ok anyway let's go back
probably don't really see what is
playing now I mean I was threatening
this I thought yeah come on take take
the night if you want I have a night to
capture as well ok play if then I was
amazed they sometimes place so amazingly
quickly even in super concreted sharp
positions I mean I tend to invest a bit
too much time which also yeah as
simulation to the to the commentary of
course but I really don't understand why
the queen is trapped why you need to
play so quickly sometimes and then get
into such positions ok look yeah
probably look everyone protect the Earth
porn we should be five can you can play
to do now just Queen g5 to e7 as one
idea or 94 it's just a queen queen for
look
98 a thought but maybe there's something
something stronger I can also cover this
first
yeah just between jeez have made no a
few moves at Queen g8 f7 is protected
twice yeah I really think that my
attacker was unsound at first at least I
mean this this this F for this looks on
sound I'm a bit at least or the computer
thinks I'm winning okay yeah II 598
seven-year the computer thinks white is
an excellent shape andy sixx winsome
yeah then was really so bad for him as I
at first thought we need seven I'd look
strange somehow in this traffic jam
Europe in this pin and after f4 he needs
to react properly the best move actually
is H form yeah family Haley typical
takes a 94 this is the big idea this
gives black white good play interesting
play at least this is coming but ok you
played this in two seconds so no chance
to find age four and after this black is
in big trouble already now after this
does f5 the typical moves I didn't
recalculate it I just thought okay this
is normal especially if the age part is
moved then it's always this capture be
should be 394 there's other things on
the on the king and i conned us on + 34
white so there's even very concrete
things happening here i just did it yeah
like based on intuition didn't calculate
much but um okay here yeah this is
busted cannot cannot live with those
pawns it's just not possible let's see
if I screwed up in the realization
process somehow
doesn't seem that way and this yeah just
wins the house yeah takes Andrew f7
winning the Queen app yeah he just
played all this a bit too quickly and
got into this big troll always need to
check f45 in the Benoni it's really
dangerous of course the main idea of
white yeah thanks for watching